danny me espera ganar empatar o perder
con la misma frecuencia en el juego de
piedra papel o tijera danning juega a
menudo piedra papel o tijera pero
sospecha que sus propios juegos no
siguen ese patrón por lo tanto decide
tomar una muestra aleatoria de 24 juegos
y registrar sus resultados he aquí lo
que obtuvo así que de estos 24 juegos
ella ganó 4 perdió tres y empató siete
ella quiere usar estos resultados para
realizar una prueba de bondad de ajuste
y cuadrada para determinar si la
distribución de sus salidas no
concuerdan con una distribución uniforme
cuáles son los valores del estadístico
de prueba y del valor p para la prueba
de danny bueno pausa el vídeo e intenta
contestar por tu cuenta
esencialmente lo que ella está haciendo
es una prueba de hipótesis usando un
estadístico y cuadrada porque tenemos
una hipótesis que está pensando acerca
de múltiples categorías así que cuál
sería su hipótesis nula la hipótesis
nula va a ser que todas sus salidas
tienen la misma probabilidad
mientras que la hipótesis alternativa
será que todas sus salidas no tienen la
misma probabilidad
y recuerda vamos a suponer que la
hipótesis nula es verdadera y si la
probabilidad de obtener un resultado tan
extremo es lo suficientemente baja
entonces rechazaremos la hipótesis nula
otra forma de pensarlo es que si nuestro
valor p está por debajo de cierto umbral
entonces rechazaremos la hipótesis nula
entonces lo que ella hizo fue tomar una
muestra aleatoria de 24 juegos entonces
n es igual a 24 y estos fueron los
resultados que ella obtuvo ahora antes
de calcular nuestro estadístico y
cuadrada y encontrar cuál es la
probabilidad de obtener una ji cuadrada
así de grande o mayor veamos si se
cumplen las condiciones para la
inferencia para realizar la prueba de
bondad de ajuste cuadrada la primera es
la condición de aleatoriedad y ésta nos
habla de que en realidad
una muestra aleatoria de juegos pero es
justo lo que nos dicen aquí ella decide
tomar una muestra aleatoria de 24 juegos
por lo tanto podemos decir que se cumple
esta condición
la segunda condición es la condición de
frecuencias esperadas y esta es una
condición importante nos dice que el
número esperado de salidas de cada
categoría debe de ser al menos igual a 5
y puedes estar tentado a decir oye oye
oye aquí tenemos solamente cuatro
victorias dane obtuvo cuatro victorias
de sus 24 juegos pero esto no viola la
condición de frecuencias esperadas
recuerda cuál es el valor esperado de
juegos ganados perdidos y empatados
bueno si suponemos que la hipótesis nula
es verdadera donde todas las salidas
tienen la misma probabilidad entonces el
valor esperado será que cada uno tenga
un tercio un tercio y un tercio de
probabilidad y un tercio de 24 es 8
y ocho y ocho eso es lo que esperaría
danny y como todos estos valores
esperados son al menos iguales a cinco
entonces podemos decir que se cumplen
esta condición de frecuencias esperadas
y la última condición es la condición de
independencia si no estamos mostrando
con reemplazo se cumplen esta condición
si el tamaño de la muestra es menor que
el 10% de la población y yo creo que en
definitiva ella puede jugar más de 240
juegos en toda su vida por lo tanto
podemos suponer que también se cumple
esta condición y ya que tenemos estas
tres condiciones es momento de calcular
nuestro estadístico y cuadrada e
intentar hacer algo de inferencia con
base en el nuestro estadístico y
cuadrada
va a ser igual a quien para cada
categoría es la diferencia al cuadrado
del valor obtenido menos el valor
esperado esto dividido entre el valor
esperado por lo tanto para la primera
categoría de victorias tenemos 4 menos 8
al cuadrado
4 - 8 esto elevado al cuadrado y
dividido entre el valor esperado que es
8 ya esto le vamos a sumar y nos vamos a
la siguiente categoría a la categoría de
derrotas ella perdió 13 veces por lo
tanto me va a quedar 13
- el valor esperado de esa categoría que
es 8 esto elevado al cuadrado y también
dividido entre el valor esperado que es
8 ya esto le vamos a sumar y bueno tengo
7 que es el número de veces que ella
empató me quedara 7 menos 8 que es el
valor esperado para esta categoría esto
elevado al cuadrado y dividido entre el
valor esperado de esta categoría que es
y veamos cuánto es esto 4 - 8 bueno eso
es menos 4 elevado al cuadrado me va a
dar 16 16
octavos ya esto le puedo sumar bueno
13 - 8 5 elevado al cuadrado es 25 25
octavos ok ya esto le voy a sumar y
después tengo 7 81 al cuadrado es 11
octavo lo cual me da exactamente lo
mismo que en 16 más 25 más 1 es 42
octavos 42 octavos
es lo mismo que 8 por 5 es 40 y me
quedan dos octavos que es punto 25 por
lo tanto ya puedo decir que mi valor y
cuadrada es igual a 5.25 y ahora nuestro
valor pm va a ser igual a la
probabilidad
de obtener quién bueno de obtener un
estadístico cuadrada mayor o igual a
5.25 y bueno para esto necesitamos sacar
nuestra tabla para este valor p claro
sin olvidar nuestros grados de libertad
tenemos una dos tres categorías por lo
tanto nuestros grados de libertad serán
uno menos que la cantidad de categorías
tres menos uno es dos por lo tanto
nuestros grados de libertad en esta
ocasión son dos y esto tiene sentido
porque para un cierto número de juegos
si ya conoces el número de victorias y
el número de derrotas puedes encontrar
el número de empates o si conoces
cualquiera de estas dos categorías
siempre puedes encontrar la tercera es
por eso que tenemos dos grados de
libertad así que es hora de sacar
nuestra tabla para la gi cuadrada
tenemos dos grados de libertad
así que estamos en esta fila y donde
estan 5.25 bueno 5.25 está por aquí
entre este valor de pm de 0.10 y este
valor de pm de 0.05 por lo tanto nuestra
probabilidad estarán entre 0 puntos 10 y
entre 0.05 vamos a escribirlo nuestro
valor pm será mayor que 0.05 y menor que
cero punto 10
así que por ejemplo si con anterioridad
y ella debió de haber hecho esto con
anterioridad establece un nivel de
significancia del 5% y nuestro valor pm
es mayor que el 5% que es justo lo que
acabamos de ver entonces no podríamos
rechazar la hipótesis nula pero no nos
preguntan eso lo que nos preguntan es
cuál es el valor de g cuadrada y en qué
rango está nuestro valor p
así que veamos 5.5 está en estas dos
opciones y obtuvimos un valor pm entre
el 5% y el 10% por lo tanto mi opción
correcta am es la opción a y hemos
terminado nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo hasta la próxima